il est trop beau bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors une
phrase est ressorti de cet hommage
public hier à minneapolis tu as changé
le monde
georges propos d' al sharpton pasteur et
militant des droits civiques la sphère
george frey peut-elle réellement
bousculer le racisme structurel aux
états unis à votre avis à l'écouter elle
y contribuera certainement mais les
propos de d'un château ne sont peut-être
trop optimiste parce que ce problème de
racisme et de violence policière et de
violence tout court d'ailleurs existe
depuis très longtemps aux états unis et
c'est cette une
c'est une caractéristique de la société
américaine que que l'on n'arrive pas à
résoudre
donald trump a déclaré mardi soir
qu'aucun président américain n'avait
fait autant pour la communauté afro
américaine depuis abraham lincoln
comment une telle phrase at elle été
aperçu par la communauté afro américaine
est ce qu'une partie d'entre elle
soutient donald trump
écoutez c'est dans ses propos excessifs
et à l'emporte-pièce de donald trump
parce que c'est quand même loin de la
réalité
donald trump s'est clairement prononcé
en faveur de la police au moment d'aider
ses bottes de ferguson en 2015 au moment
où déjà les violences policières étaient
annoncés il a dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'il n'appartenait pas au gouvernement
fédéral de contrôle et des polices qui
comme vous le savez aux états unis sans
local et puis on sait que au moment
d'aider des incidents de charleville
il avait également renvoyé dos à dos les
extrémistes des deux camps et on lui
avait reproché à l'époque de ne pas
avoir pris fait et cause pour les
afro-américains donc non ce serait pas
c'est ça mais certainement pas exact de
dire qu'il a fait plus que tous les
présidents le président obama par
exemple même s'il avait une politique
relativement centriste a quand même par
sa réforme de l'assurance santé fait
beaucoup plus pour les communautés afro
américaine
derek chauveau le policier ans qui a tué
john floyd lors de son interpellation
est désormais inculpé d'homicide
volontaire et non plus d'homicide
involontaire
la pression de la rue at elle pu selon
vous avoir une incidence sur la décision
du procureur général
oui très certainement très certainement
l'un des grands problèmes de des
violences policières c'est que le les
auteurs policiers un de ces violences
sont très rarement condamnés et ils sont
très rarement condamnés parce que
quelquefois les affaires ne sont pas
très clair lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'utilisation de leur arme de service
par exemple c'est une décision qui se
prend une fraction de seconde qui peut
être une mauvaise décision mais qui peut
parfois relever de la légitime défense
là le policier avec son genou sur le
coup de georges floyd n'était pas du
tout en situation d'échec une défense
donc la situation est beaucoup plus
claire et et il sera donc plus difficile
de tenir estime défense et il ne serait
pas étonnant qu'il soit condamné
alors on voit aller les manifestations
qui se poursuivent dans le pays
on a noté comme une violence qui est en
net recul mais qu'est ce qui pourrait
arrêter cette révolte populaire aux
états unis c'est une rien en un sens
rien ne l'arrêtera parce que ce sont des
révoltes qui sont récurrentes il y a eu
les émeutes de détroit en 1965 il y a eu
les les émeutes après le tabassage de
rodney king à los angeles en 1992 il y a
eu les émeutes de faire plus simple en
donc c'est un nouvel épisode le
l'actualité passera probablement autre
chose mais c'est très certainement une
question qui comme par exemple la
circulation des armes à feu reviendra
dans l'actualité à
à espace régulier et c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement difficile à résoudre
parce que c'est pas seulement une
question de violences policières
c'est aussi comme l'a dit d'ailleurs le
chanteur c'est aussi une question de
politique pénale qui sont extrêmement
sévères aux états unis qui impacte très
particulièrement les afro-américains qui
fait qu'un homme américain entre 30
entre 20 et 35 ans un homme américain
sur dix est en prison mais avec un par
un sur dix sept ans de prison
on est à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles
jobs hayden et donald trump sont en
campagne à quel point cette cette
affaire georges floy peut-elle porter
préjudice à donald trump
alors elle peut porter préjudice à
donald trump parce que les
afro-américains vote assez massivement
pour les démocrates
mais très souvent ni s'abstiennent et
donc là la question ça va être pour joe
biden de mobiliser l'électorat
afro-américain et ses manifestations
participent à leur mobilisation pour
faire battre dolan donald trump d'une
part mais aussi pour forcer joe biden à
avoir des politiques qu'ils soient plus
affirmative en quelque sorte à l'égard
de la une des communautés afro
américains didier combis merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé à l'institut
des amériques et auteur de l'ouvragé
être américain aujourd'hui les enjeux
d'une élection présidentielle aux
éditions gallimard